the openings are so hard they're sort of
what are you supposed to do in the
openings what what's the best openings
for you to play and why so I had a lot a
lot of questions when I started to play
chess cuz I really didn't know what was
a good openings
I discovered because I lost so many
games I discovered that the best
openings for me were those were I could
develop my pieces quickly when I started
I thought it was really good to bring
out my Queen and I moved my queen all
over the board and I forgot to ever
develop the rest of my pieces the crazy
part is sometimes I won the game by
doing that but usually it was a very bad
idea and oftentimes I'd lose my queen
and if I lost my queen I I didn't even
know how to play chess my Queen was so
important to me but then I got better
and I realized that the best thing I
could do in the openings is to get my
pieces off the first or last rank as
quickly as I could
I discovered gambits do you guys know
gambits
you know a good gambit I bet what a
gambit is a gambit is where I
deliberately sacrifice a pawn or two or
even three or sacrifice a piece usually
a knight to get ahead in development and
I'd like to show you an example of a
gambit that I'd like to play so first of
all how many of you would like to play
this move okay
very good so now I'm gonna hit you guys
with a gambit to explain what I would
try to do
to get better at chess I tried to get
all my pieces as quickly off the back
row as possible except for my king I
wanted my king and safety that was
important to me so I'm going to play d5
UK I'm attacking your phone so what are
you guys gonna do take dope on you bet
yes so check this out I'm a pawn down in
the time count right at this moment we
would say that White has one black has
zero
black has nothing he's developed nothing
but it's one pawn more and White's ahead
in the time count let me play this move
I'm attacking your pawn what are you
gonna do how are you you're not gonna
take my time no we're gonna take the pun
how many like to take the pawn it's a
good move
you take the pawn okay so now let's just
let's just see what's happened now I'm
down two pawns I'm going to recapture
the pawn and now what's the time count
zero for white oh oh you mean well right
now in terms of material white is a pawn
up but in terms of the time count black
I'm the only one who's developed a unit
I'm ahead one to nothing what would you
like white to do what's a good move for
white men Knight to F F F three okay now
how many of you guys like White's
position he's a pawn up right yeah I
like White's position too but I also
like blacks position so right now the
score is one to one and the time count
but you guys are leading
in the material count I'm going to play
e5 so now I'm ahead version what would
you Bishop to b5 you guys are doing
really really good because now it's 2 to
2 in the time count and you're still
ahead upon I'm going to attack your
knight yeah alright then again what
Bishop takes Knight check now you guys
didn't really have to give up your
Bishop at this point it's ok if you
wanted to now at this exact moment we
stop again and what's the score to 2-1
but I'm ahead
I have two you have one guess what that
night better move but the knight doesn't
move I'm going to capture it
fashion Queen e2 is a good move that
pins my pawn against my king you guys
all see that that's a good move let's
say I bring my knight up now by the way
it's 2 1 2 3 blue yeah pawn to d3 okay
now you guys are attacking my pawn
that's really good I like what you guys
are doing I'm gonna move my Bishop here
and Lady sorry
yeah I'm attacking the pawn but I'm also
for the moment my idea was to pin I'm
hoping you'll take my pawn and my Bishop
will take your cream yes pawn to c4 ok
so how many of you like this move
it's a little tricky because careful pay
attention if you your pawn on d3 is
protected by the pawn on c2 if you move
your pawn here you're giving me the
opportunity to capture your pawn with my
queen
then I get my pawn back and I'll be
ahead in the time so another young man
what would you do
Knight to c3 very good see you guys are
actually doing pretty good because
you're you're bringing your pieces out
fast I'm trying to bring my pieces out
fast and you guys you captured upon and
you're doing very very well I'm gonna
bring my bishop out so my bishop pins
your knight to the king castle very very
good when you start thinking and
counting on the time count you start to
realize what a wonderful wonderful move
castles is because you bring two pieces
into play at once so at the moment it's
one two three four five six six for
white one two three four five
but it's my move six seven okay
oh now we have to start to think again
when you played the move Queen to e2 the
Queen pinned the pond against my king I
just moved my king well okay so the
point was was that a moment ago I could
not capture your knight I could not
capture now I can capture your knight
yes Knight to g5 okay you move your
knight now this is also important one
two three four five six one two three
four five six seven when I capture your
pawn what have I done is I've captured a
pawn that's in the time count for you so
I've taken away one of your time counts
one two three four five a moment ago you
had six now you only have five I'm
attacking your Queen my bishop is
protecting the pawn my queen is
protecting the pawn
what are you guys going to do young man
pawn takes d3 pretty good what what do
you guys think I'm going to do next
Bishop takes d3 now what has happened is
I I won yes young lady that
exactly well my bishop is about to take
the Queen when the Queen moves I'm going
to take the rook so that will be a
skewer tactic okay but let's count what
happened one two three four five one two
three four five six I won my pawn back
and I'm about to win material the gambit
paid off for me
that worked out pretty well let's go
back to the start because remember at
the start you're white and you guys have
the advantage you have the opening move
you get to bring out your pawns and
pieces before I do but what you just saw
was a gambit where I deliberately
sacrificed upon to get ahead in the
mature to get ahead in the time count
let's do it again okay we'll do a
different one this time you make a
different opening move we're gonna be
really clever this time let's say you
guys open up with the Queen pot yes
sergeant what do you think
d 5 and c4 okay
so this of course is the queen pawn
opening and I like to do a different
kind of a gambit
I played Knight f6 okay I develop my
knight our gem this is the gambit that
now c4 is the most common move the top
grandmasters in the world play c4 on
their second turn so at this very moment
it's two to one clear now what I would
do is I would play c5 attacking White's
Center
yong-man pawn III is a is a decent move
very good move also very good move is
Knight f3 protecting the pot probably
not such a good move his pawn takes pawn
but the most popular move everybody
played this move against me is to
advance the pond this is what everybody
in the world the grandmasters Garry
Kasparov Anatoly Karpov the world
champions Magnus Carlsen they all
advanced the pawns they think that
that's the best move for white is to get
the pawns in the center up the board
what's the time count exactly at this
moment - 2 - pretty basic pretty simple
right now comes the bet now comes my
gambit and the gambit was originally
discovered or created by a grandmaster
by the name of pal like do you want to
be my pal pal Benko was his name and pal
Benko he lives in new york he was
originally from the country of hungary
how many of you know the country hungary
ok pal Benko and i thought it was a
great idea he played this move
young lady what do you think the pond
correct so so now at this moment it's 1
to 2 with 2 to 2 and you guys are a pond
up now pal Benko plays this MOU
attacking the fine young lady right b5
captures a six now
exactly exactly in this moment it's two
ponds for you 2 2 2 then what I would do
is I would take the pond so now I'm only
a pond down I'm only a pond down but
what's the result 1 2 3 3 2 1 so I'm now
ahead in the time count
I didn't mind being behind a pond or
even 2 but I wanted to get my pieces off
the back rank now another thing I'd like
your opinion because a lot of
grandmasters aren't sure so I'd like to
take a poll of the class now think about
this for a moment because in the history
of chess hundreds and hundreds of years
of history they always argue about
certain important points big arguments
so here's the question for you blacks
rook on a 8 has not moved correct it's
not moved but in this position
would you consider that this rook is
developed even though it hasn't moved do
you think that rook is good how many of
you think that rook is effective raise
your hand if you think it's effective ok
how many of you think that even though
it may be effective you shouldn't count
in the time count okay so this has been
a big big controversy for many years and
you know to take your opinion and to
know what you think a lot of
grandmasters do that so now in my
opinion I actually count like this black
has moved his night for one his pawn for
two his Bishop for three
I actually count the rook and I say rook
for four why because there's no pawn in
front of the rook so I consider the rook
developed because it has a chance to
attack this pawn so for a lot of people
we actually say one two three four other
people who are we call them
traditionalist say it only counts when
you move the piece so right now I say
four to one so I'm happy to give up one
pawn to take a lead of three shall we
make a move for white Knight to c3 so
now it's 2 to 4 ok now here's where I
want you to think a little bit I'm ahead
and the time count for black I'm playing
the black side I'm ahead in the time
count and I want to continue to develop
my army I got a problem is this bishop
good how many of you think the bishops
good I don't think the bishops good the
bishop it can't move if I try to develop
the bishop this way on the f8 to a3
diagonal if I try to develop the bishop
this way guess what I got a problem
right Mike exactly two pawns are
blocking so I want to develop my bishop
in a different way I'll play g7 g6
if I put my bishop here is anybody
blocking it only the night only the
night okay I'll play g6 what move will
you guys play young man Bishop to g5
that's pretty good you're developing a
piece I'll go here now let's count
there's a second one two three one two
three four five six I'm still counting
the rook even though you may not that's
another good move for white oh yeah
Bishop takes f6 okay that's an even
trade but now what's blocking my bishop
that thing my dishes empty okay go ahead
continue the game who would what what
move is good for white and man
pawn to h3 okay this is probably okay
but but keep in mind what I'm trying to
do in this this whole lecture is to try
to urge you to move your pieces off the
back rank now yeah let me castle now
let's count for a second castling is
really good because that just really
boosted me in the time count one two
three four five six maybe seven six or
seven we're not sure I'm gonna say seven
one two three
so right now I'm really far ahead what
does it mean when I'm far ahead in the
time count it means I get to attack you
so be careful what will you do
are you e to e four okay so now one two
three four okay in this position I'm
going to capture your Bishop so I'm
going to let you recapture with the king
okay so now you can't Castle you can't
castle when you fit when you fail the
castle remember our whole army is a team
right and you got to talk to your team
members and you got to ask them how they
are feeling are they feeling good when
the white general talked to the rook on
h1 and asks him how he is feeling what
do you think the rook is saying very sad
it's not he's not happy it's going to
take white a number of moves to get that
rook into play okay let me play d6 your
turn all right what do you want to do
yes
Knight g1
- I'm gonna go night b8 d7 f2 f3 so now
you're really making a very nice chain
yeah I like that that's a good way of
putting it chain okay I'm going to bring
my queen here now now what am i
attacking right go ahead Russia the b2
pond see because I'm ahead in time it
means I'm going to get to attack you
guys faster than you can attack me and
then what do you think I'm attacking the
pawn on b2 knight on c3 goes to a for
attacking my queen now remember when I
was asking you a while ago what was this
rook developed and then maybe some of
you were doubtful you can see that in
this position I could take the knight I
could take the knight you would take my
rook I could take the pawn so I could
sacrifice an exchange for development
but how about this move how about I move
my Queen here I'm attacking the knight
with the Queen as well as with the rook
so now again let's see let's do the time
count one two three four five six seven
eight maybe nine one two three four five
six seven
but you guys how about an extra pawn
what do you hunt
you're ready to give me your rock young
man what do you I will take the night
young man what do you beef but if you
play b3 I thanks to my open bishop I
could take a rock would you be happy now
who would be ahead yes yeah Knight a to
c3 okay but that means that you've come
back and I'll recapture my pawn whoo so
now we're even-steven and I have a lead
in development one of the at a certain
moment in the game I stopped using the
time count I no longer think about the
time count when do you think you should
stop counting at what time Arjun when do
you stop counting so when you took my
knight the the was there a drumroll and
that's the end of the opening everybody
I'm not sure so I define it as follows
when do I stop using the time count the
moment my rooks are connected the moment
the rooks are connected I say the
opening is over and I start thinking
about material in space okay in this
moment I've done really well I'd like to
show you another gambit for a moment
okay this is a pretty cool gambit in
this gambit I sacrifice a piece that's
pretty good let's see how I could
sacrifice a piece
this pattern or this opening comes from
the rulli Lopez white opens with his
King pon efore black responds in kind he
5 the classical King pawn defense how
many of you played this position and
played Knight f3 yeah me too
he attacked the pawn on e5 black plays
Knight c6 defending the pawn now the
next move was invented in the 15th
century by a Spanish priest by the name
of Lopez and he wrote a book about his
experiences and this move gets his name
the rule of PES okay so now black plays
a6 attacking the bishop margin what
that's the question
what should you do some people play
Bishop a4 some people take the knight
how many of you like to take the knight
ok very good
this is one of the top moves Bishop
takes c6 and when I was guessing lady
yes I took this way pawn takes the
bishop no white castles ok that's the
best move by the way castles exactly in
this moment after the bishop captured
what's the time count
three did so but blacks ahead in the
time count right so Wow
white started the game and Oh already
he's behind in the time count okay white
castle's
and exactly in this moment it's one two
three four four two three
so castling is accelerated White's
development I'm black I would play the
move Bishop to g4 and I'm pinning the
night against the Queen pawn to h3 pawn
to h3 attacks my bishop and asked me the
same question that black asked about
this bishop over here what are you gonna
do are you gonna take the knight are you
yes that was the move I like to play I
love the move h7 h5 am I crazy did I
just leave my bishop in capture how many
of you think I made a terrible mistake
yeah I do you guys mind if I take my
move back will you allow me to take my
move back
didn't you ever want to take a move back
never
I made it oh come on I made a mistake
I thought could please okay your turn
will you take my bishop oh you guys are
really mean I'm telling you after this
class I'm gonna talk to the club and say
these kids they're they're just horrible
okay you took my bishop that's worth
three I took your pawn that right
exactly how many would like to take the
eighth I thought yeah Wow Wow a free
pawn so how many of happy now with white
yes so that's one pawn oh these bishops
are off the board so you guys have a
whole night more now remember a moment
ago I was asking a very key question was
that rook on a eight in that Banco
gambit developed and how many thought it
was and how many thought it was not and
how many weren't sure now we're gonna
reverse it for a moment
see this rook how many counted is
developed how many say it hasn't moved
so it's not developed that's ridiculous
I can't this rook as developed even
though it hasn't moved because it's on
the open file now I'm going to play that
that how many of you saw this coming
I'm going to play Queen to h4
and what's my threat what's my threat
correct I can go down to h2 or h1 you
guys are a night ahead I know you're
happy but you're facing checkmate mmm by
the way what's the time count 1 2 3 4 I
say 1 2 3 4 5 even though black isn't
ahead that much in the time count he's
threatening checkmate what do you want
it well as soon as I move my room if I
were to make a castles then I would
count it at this moment I'm not counting
the rook because if the Proms in the way
I am counting this rook because it's
open now because I'm threatening
checkmate here Queen h2 I'm threatening
checkmate here what can white do
possibly yes
f3 probably you have two moves in fact
you could probably play f3 to give your
King a square or f4 same idea we'll go
with f3 for a moment now what can I do
yes yeah yes the black palm can take the
white pawn whether you got to be careful
how many of you would like to play check
not so good right but I got a better
move how many of you'd like to play this
check and then when the King moves
you could take the night right how many
of you like Queen h2 check that's pretty
good
you get to win back your night but
there's a even a very very strong move
in the physician young man what do you
think yeah so you played g3 what this
move does it stops the yeah it blocks
the King from moving and white cannot
stop checkmate yes your men then if I go
here indeed your king can run away but I
would not go to h2 where do you think
I'd go a quad then your King can't run
anywhere and it's checkmate that
checkmate came out of the blue right
white was doing okay that's patterns as
you start to play more and more chess
you start to realize that openings
contain a lot of patterns what I'd like
you to do in your games like this week
or next is try some gambits
don't be afraid to go ahead sacrifice
some pawns and to try to get ahead in
the time count that's so crucial in the
openings are there any questions any of
you have any questions about openings
how it went how it's good yeah should I
show you the rook sacrifice that I saw
earlier today yes young lady would you
like to see a rook sacrifice now a
moment ago I just showed you prawn
sacrifices I showed you a bishop
sacrifice I was coming in to give the
lecture today and I saw two young
brothers and they were playing and the
game went be 45 Knight came out Knight
came out Bishop came out how many of you
played this position before
oh yeah goodnight came out attacking the
palm and I came here attacking this pawn
okay
the bishop came out here to c5 and white
captured the pawn on f7 so this move
attacks the Queen and tax the rook oh
this efficie
be careful that bishop protects the
night so you can't capture black
captured this pawn with check whoa
that's wild what are you King f1 that
was what was plague King f1 was the move
that was played black moved his Queen
and white captured the rook oh my
so look at this black is down an entire
rook and what's the time count one two
three four one two three four five but
is it worth a whole rook whoo we don't
know yet so black in this moment he
dropped his bishop back to b6 then what
happened well you guys played what what
did your brother do now
you played Knight c3 okay and then you
played Queen C Queen the c5 attacking
the bishop
what else does black threaten what else
yes but black has a threat what is black
threat anyway
checkmate Queen f2 white played Bishop
f7 check to get his Bishop out and black
made a mistake he moved his King here he
should have brought his King here
he moved his King here
and then to protect against the
checkmate Queen e2 right Queen e2
protected the checkmate
and then d6y sd-6 was played d3 was
played the bishop came out attacking the
Queen this I this is one of my favorite
moves in chess gaining development with
tempo black moves his Bishop off the
back rank and attacks the Queen forcing
white to move his Queen and so black
gets an extra move in the time count did
you play Queen e1 or Queen right Queen
e1 and then did you move your king or
you denied came some Knight d4 then it
was like night a four night 8th Oh Queen
f2 King f8 Knight a 4
Queen takes c2 are coming to the end
Knight takes b6 now everybody take a
quick look at this position imagine that
you had the black pieces and you were
playing in the World Championship for
under 12 years old and if you won the
game you win the gold medal and you have
the black pieces okay so you've got to
find a move that will win the gold medal
what with black black to play and win
the gold medal young lady what would you
do
yeah but then it would just be a trade
Queen takes Queen check King takes f2 it
it's just even-steven trade young man
what do you think
Queen to where Queen to d1 check
are you a hundred percent sure that that
would win the gold medal
only if you're a hundred percent sure
it's the gold medal young man is he
right is he right
did that win the game yes
from the hoe Bishop e2 check to the king
how many saw that move so what happens
if we move the King here are we and
that's checkmate so there you go it was
a great game I just happened to before
the lecture thank you all for coming
remember that during the week there's a
lot of events there's a lot of
tournaments there's a lot of quads and
you're all welcome so thank you have a
great weekend